welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question this is the show where
we give you too much information about
all the nerdy curveballs that are flung
in our direction that bettering speed
like you know the new Batsuit worn by
Robert Pattinson in the latest test
footage for the Batman coming next year
this is Eric boss this is Villa Molina I
go up here and we're gonna we're gonna
answer the biggest questions for you and
this week Philip the big questions all
about yes this new bad suit how is it
engineered how is it design been updated
to suit this new Batman essentially what
secrets are the new Betsy let's see are
you hiding see that your jacket zipped
up what are you talking about this
jacket zip up this jacket let's show the
footage okay don't you see we'll get
there guys the big question about this
bat suit is definitely about this emblem
right that's what everybody's talking
about
we will get to the emblem I promise you
in fact we got into some fisticuffs
about it yes but I just want to start
top-down right so if we start at the top
it would be the ears except you can't
see the ears on this guy but I actually
pulled up a bunch of mock-ups of
different designs that we can show on
screen right now oh I'm saying these are
things that would be might be you're
just looking at me saying but it's
applying to you know others are just
gonna show you licking your lips are
zipped up so let's keep going down that
sexy so see you oh yeah a huge heavy
furrowed brow uh and we get to the
all-important mask slash cowl this is
usually the most definitive part of the
look right this is what people decide
that's what this Batman looks like and
this one the most unique thing just
right out of the gate you can see it
here even is the leather stitching yeah
all around the mask we've never seen
that before
except for terrible cosplayers you can
see just all the seams of their outfits
this is where the duct tape is but it
was intentional let's show my favorite
cosplay costume I've ever seen oh great
okay so this stitching immediately
implies that this is some sort of
material poly leather honestly but the
question is why isn't it like all the
others which are usually some variation
on I there's some sort of ceramic or
Kevlar material so here's the thing
scientists have kind of looked into hey
should we
we improve our military's helmets by
creating full mask of made of Kevlar to
prevent them from bullets to the head
and being deadly it turns out they're
still deadly if you do that a Kevlar
helmet would that is thin enough to wear
in a scenario like this actually does
not prevent your skull from fracturing
doesn't prevent concussions it still
will give you brain damage so at that
point it's actually false confidence
giver that you know I can just get shot
in the head right right it's
counterproductive yeah it's like that
guy in Saving Private Ryan even if he
kept it on yeah that poor poor actor
that they killed Fred scene why do they
insist on doing that yeah realism it's
not Kevlar and that's okay it's not
stupid
Aaron but why specifically leather
leather as it turns out is is just
lighter in general on your head but it's
specifically very comfortable and
comfortable doesn't seem that important
except it's comfortable because it's
form-fitting and actually the more he
wears it the more it's gonna give to his
exact kind of weird skull shape if you
look at the skull we got a picture of a
skull file photo of Pattinson skull so
it's not just love it because it's it's
comfortable leather actually has been
used as a helmet a bunch of times
famously when you were playing football
back in 1906 yes yeah Oh shiny they
called them leather heads right right
yeah
those you would always think oh well
those stupid idiots were getting brain
damage and obviously didn't work too
well actually the Cleveland Clinic just
did a study pretty recently that found
that those leather football helmets are
equally and sometimes better protecting
football players from brain injury than
the most modern current polycarbonate
heads but do you think it's because the
football players now are ten times the
size that they were back in the slip
well no they can actually put on one of
these beefy freaks of nature they can
put a leather helmet on it and it will
protect him better in or at least the
same than his current helmet Wow but the
exception is it is less likely to
predict protect against a skull fracture
so if it's like you know head going into
a knee or something then he probably was
fracture your skull but the new ones
actually are probably more likely to
cause concussions oh wow yeah so it
actually is a very good strong use of a
lightweight material and in fact
firefighters
a leather home it's pretty frequently
they don't all wear them it's a choice
that they make but another reason is
because they deal with extreme
temperatures really well which Batman
gone into a burning building you know or
setting fire to the side of a building
in the shape of a bat look yes this guy
is a little too liberal yep and a little
bit of a narcissist but you know what
it's worth it cuz he's a leather daddy
now which makes it all worth it right
welcome to the club
let's keep going down this thing so we
explain my leathers better you can see
that the mouth hole is actually a lot
bigger in the cowl that's just so you
can talk bigger smack that's not sure or
to take bigger things in there Eric
leather Danny
Eric Eric your family's watching this
episode yeah but they don't understand
why their family's watching and that's
why I'm shouting them out so much so we
keep going down past this holes and we
get to this neck actually there's a
better image being put on screen a lot
of people are noticing that there's kind
of this raised collar like a popped up
yuppie some people are thinking that
this could be a reference to Gotham by
Gaslight which is an awesome story I'm
very into else world Batman stories that
pitch them all the time
it's starring me in every role but it's
kind of similar ensure that there's a
there's a raise collar in that but
actually I think this is more tactical I
think it's actually inspired by
basically a SWAT suit which a lot of the
rest of it is too if you look well show
some images here if you look they're
often wearing neck protection in the
form of an expanded collar sure yeah
that both is against a potential bullet
or knife attack or something but the
neck is like this vital place that is
often not protected if you if you don't
have a raised thing but they always get
this wrong on bat suits every version of
the bat suit they've been trying to
figure out how do we protect the neck
without building it into the cowl so
even you know recently they created some
sort of weird sliding system and Ben
Affleck sued so that he literally just
could turn his head left and right yeah
it's more for like design to avoid that
whole joke from the first run of Batman
would they had to turn their whole body
he could he had to turn his entire torso
to look out the side of the planes and
give a thumbs-up do you know that's not
his arm
what was the Val Kilmer Michael Keaton
they had to have a whole other person it
was Michael Keaton's are
Gilmer it's the arm abandoned yeah yeah
they had that problem they actually
tried to address it also in the dark
night where in the dark night he tries
get an upgraded version and Lucius Fox
specifically says you want to be able to
move your neck don't you get when you
back down the driveway right and they
still actually didn't really nail it he
can just kind of turn it this is the
first time that they were like why don't
we just separate the neck protection
from the mask entirely yeah so they just
raised it out on the sides and now he's
able to move his head in any way he can
go he can do all the stories that full
the ball joint that we have yeah ball
and socket joint yeah let's let's make
Michael Keaton and Val Kilmer jealous or
something no I can do all kinds of
thumbs up here I go thumbs up down here
ceiling cam all the leather daddies that
we lost before we're trying to protect
us that's actually a really cool choice
that they made is to just actually give
him more mobility in the neck which is
an important place to have mobility but
still not sacrifice the protection if
you keep going down that then you see
the Cape not much to tell other than it
looks like it might be detachable Oh
which makes a lot of freaking sense
probably the worst example of a cape
that doesn't make sense is Michael
Keaton's because Tim Burton obviously
was going for a stylistic bat inspired
look and he's very goth inspired it's
like you know a gargoyle watching over
you or something you know gargoyles in
their capes oh yeah but it's all part of
his costume and like is built into the
emblem and the the cowl and all somebody
have to do if Batman was running was
like just catches Kate didn't because
like oh I can't
ping nothing so the fact that this one
might be detachable honestly it just
makes a lot of sense you might be able
to have better mobility with that and
that actually brings me to the suit
where it is just incredibly practical as
what it seems like it does look like the
similar to the Kevlar buy we body armor
that was used in the Nolan films and
that's kind of what looks like his
around his chest his arms his upper
shoulders and and whatnot
remember I was telling you that in the
Dark Knight Christian Bale's Batman
upgrades his his suit because he's not
moving quickly enough he's not agile
enough
and so they come up with a new version
that has these kind of plates instead of
a solidified piece he kind of seems to
have these plates to Pattinson suit
where you can kind of see it around the
shoulder and stuff where it's more
separated the issue with that that he
might run into is actually that that
version of the suit is more susceptible
to small arms gunfire and two knife
attack which Talia al Ghul made use of
in Dark Knight Rises yeah yeah if he had
not upgraded to suit she might not have
been able to stab him on the side okay
so based on all of this being so kind of
realistic for just being in attack mode
all the time that I'll throw back to the
ears for a sec is why I think we're
actually probably gonna see practical
small ears that aren't weirdly like if
he doesn't duck low enough for something
they might get caught on some and snap
his head back oh yeah I think well maybe
a little similar to the Ben Affleck
version those are actually pretty stubby
ears yeah cute but you know really just
for Windows there's some really cool
designs that the ears a little longer I
do hope they kind of keep those actually
but it seems like they'll probably go
practical with it that brings us to the
emblem oh yes which is the big question
of this big question so first of all it
is more visible than Christian Bale's
which I think Christopher Nolan was like
I wish I did not have to put any bats
anywhere on anything because he like hid
that one do we have to call the movie
Batman yeah I can't it be dark guy yeah
but it's way less visible than Michael
Keaton's which is the famous yellow oval
we've seen that in the comics for years
that was in the cartoon - and that one
by the way a lot of people are like
that's so stupid he's got like this
bright yellow oval right over his heart
but in the comics they've since
retroactively Lee said that that's on
purpose because it's bulletproof or
there's a bull plate behind it sometimes
and he wants people to shoot directly at
that mmm so to distract the guard
exactly but it also kind of requires a
person have amazing aim like if they
slightly are off and it's like nah crap
this is still about me right here you're
not here here this emblem specifically
okay so we can see it but what if
something looks like it's made of
something it looks like has mechanical
parts to it so there
a couple of different theories here this
part we don't know for sure and we
probably won't know until either a
trailer or the movie itself
the most popular theory right now is
that it's made from a gun yes I saw this
one specifically Joe chills gun the
murderer of his parents that would
probably be a throwback to Detective
Comics 1000 where Batman gets Joe chills
gun and he melts it down and he puts it
right there but he actually turns it
into a bulletproof plate to put behind
the emblem gives it meaning that way or
something I'm kind of into if it is a
gun it just kind of also looks really
hard to make that shape out of a gun
another theory is that it's actually
made out of knife parts and it maybe is
a functional knife or two knives which I
know that you're interested in yes and
then third a lot of people are thinking
maybe it's actually just removable in
general and maybe it is sure a knife or
a gun or something or a Batarang sure
yeah would be kind of fun if you like a
detachable piece and you just use right
here yeah II need it and he literally
only has one we just got one but it
comes back in the ring yes it can
potentially be made from gun pieces
knife pieces or just be detachable
Batarang in general but is that
realistic does that they're going so
realistic on this so this is a big
question there's no reason for us to do
this but we tried to figure out if we
could take items like guns and knives by
them without raising suspicion and
turned them into essentially that
Batarang so Eric I know you did one
based off of a knife that you had okay I
tried to do it out of a gun we'll
compare results okay well I have a knife
that we've known for past episodes a big
question I carry with me at all times
but it's far too sharp to pull out here
on the big question table because we
often accidentally injure each other on
this show and I don't want I got a gun
okay well what I decided to do was this
guy scot-free on Twitter tweeted us a
diagram based off of what you can see in
the trailer trying to show how those two
pieces the bat wings are actually
knives there are two small daggers that
you can pull out and use and if you put
them back to back you can kind of make
these kind of a retractable knives as if
it's kind of like a switchblade or a
pocketknife and I reconstructed this
using my crafty skills cutting it out of
cardboard that we I think we needed that
cardboard for something else but I
destroyed it
and and made this you gave it nipple why
did you give it an earful no sensitive
okay so imagine you're Robert Pattinson
and you're facing a dangerous situation
and you need these small knives you have
them right here wait wait wait I'm a bad
guy coming at you go oh [ __ ] what looks
like you have no weapon well very well
but I have this knife and I have it but
I just hit once where I know the
arteries will car Carter eyes and self
they self Carter eyes so what's cool
about this is like many knives they can
they can they can they could they they
can they can didn't use pencils you
could they can go and then you got a
little compact version that you can just
tote tote around in your pocket well the
point here on your chest
well that's because they aren't
expecting to check your pockets when
you're going through TSA I just want to
show everyone how cool it Erick's craft
skills are that he can you can that I
did that they do that it's plausible
nipples yeah you got your your Batman
emblem that is also a knife and that's
what I think no one even notices
[Music]
and back there on the chest ago so the
answer of can it be made from a knife
yes Duvall I mean this is kind of what
it looks like your knives
mine was tough because I had to make
mine out of a gun and first of all
getting a gun is really easy so easy
it's harder to go through TSA get on a
plane know what a gun but I went to
Target I walked the aisle saw a lot of
decent options but then I finally found
the jackpot some nerf guns okay yes and
so I took I bought a nerf gun I took it
home with me i disassembled it
we're watching the b-roll now and then I
kind of broken galata pieces I use my
Dremel on it I painted it a bit and I
ended up with it's a little bit rough
but also on my chest it's really holding
just the skin of your chest yeah it's
kind of uh former gun turn into kind of
a successful Batarang kind of has some
some folding abilities how did you make
the wings from a gun folding wings what
they were it was like gun handle gun
handle piece and then you know little
Springs or whatever you just bought a
Batarang toy and said that you made it
out of it what are you talking about you
run around why that's not a gun you just
bought a battery it's not a gun anymore
I've specifically changed it it was
always a battery no this has never been
a better and look it has tape why would
it this was a nerf gun I can make it
back into a nerf gun all right well it's
it's answered clearly you know Phillip
did a better job than Erik but it wasn't
a competition but in real life it is our
jobs depend on the view out of this is
it a Batarang made out of guns a nerf
gun that you can throw and fold up we're
just so proud of ourselves
we're like but now let's take a moment
to like talk about something that like
has been growing at new Rockstone we got
oh and scientists don't know what it is
yet the discord the private discord
server that we have that's just among
our inner circle of nerds and supporters
that has kind of started something we
just wanted to offer people and we
didn't know what it would be but it's
kind of become like our go-to place for
like
our people who we love to hear their
opinions who have like these great
theories and ideas that have kind of
made their way into our videos it's
really just like a way for us to get to
know on a more personal level but yeah
our favorite people yeah these are
people who are patrons of ours so they
could sign up be a patreon and you get
the link to discord that way but yeah I
mean under CG should we keep talking to
in here old Danny T WCC may yeah yeah
really really great people on there
shout out to all of them honestly it's
just nice to have other nerds to just
talk to you know my geek out about these
work conversations that we were already
having on slack internally and we just
realize like well we can have them with
you know fans - and we've honestly used
we've stolen all their ideas for the
videos yeah I mean this show would not
exist without that I feel like because I
think it was that feeling of getting to
know people and having a chance to
answer their questions and having giving
them a chance to get to know us better
and there's a whole separate thread
that's just IRL in real life and we get
to see like what projects they're
working on and like it's created this
nice little community of a place to like
connect with people so if you want
access to that I highly recommend it
because it's been kind of like our
favorite thing going into work every day
it's the lowest tier thing you can do to
support our channel can help us do
things made it sound like an [ __ ]
thing like it's a bare bottom so you
could work after we get drunk and build
weapons the dark our kids don't see us
my kids don't even know I exist and I
don't acknowledge their existence
because they're too busy building
weapons anyway if you'd like to support
us on patreon a discord is a great way
to show you love us and for us to show
that we love you not our kids to be
clear what kids alright moving on to
some bite-sized questions now that I
have to answer since Phillip did such a
great job talking about Batman's new
suit if I had done a bad job then I
would keep talking to redeem myself yes
all right
ooh this one's all this was mailed to us
yes you can mail us at our peel box it's
below Dirac Boston Globe lean and out
I've seen endgame fourteen million six
hundred thousand and five times I've
been thinking does cap have the
odinforce
see the power Thor had in Ragnarok
because in Thor one Odin said whoever
holds this hammer if he be worthy shall
possess the powers of Thor
since cap is worthy wouldn't he possess
that sincerely Jackson Casey PS sorry
about the construction paper I guess
I'll have to call it under Mifflin thank
you so much thanks Jackson and a great
question we're happy to clear this up
because it is so Tito we have overlooked
in past videos video that I worked on
with marina and important marina had to
go up in hostess video with a with kind
of a little fact oversight that was
totally my fault but she did a great job
with this video yes you are correct I
pointed out that Odin's worthiness charm
in Thor one does say that whoever wields
this hammer should they be worthy will
possess the powers of and because cap
the MC was decided he is worthy there
was that little detail in age of Ultron
where he's able to budget and then of
course an Avengers in game he picks it
up and he is able to summon lightning
with it yeah meaning he is worthy of the
powers of Thor including the god of
thunder powers which is just inherent
Lightning summoning abilities so yes
due to Odin's worthiness charm in Thor
one cap is worthy of the powers of Thor
including lightning powers and then also
technically Thor doesn't even need the
hammer he does to do it so maybe cap I
think he becomes the god of thunder the
moment he picks up the hammer good
answer good job Thank You Jackson what
if cap could still only just budge the
hammer even an end game watch out they
know some in your way big guy jr. Lopez
asked when spider-man twips around does
he leave webs everywhere or does it just
dissolve would there be webs all around
New York so Stan Lee established pretty
early on in the spider-man comics in the
60s that spider-man's web fluid
dissolves after an hour so after an hour
starts to go by it gets really dry and
brittle and eventually just kind of like
disintegrates into dust it's something
that Peter Parker he didn't design it
this way he actually tried to make the
spider webbing more long lasting and
durable because he wanted to try to sell
it to make money off it but he couldn't
figure out a way to do it dang it okay
well this is the best I can do so that
way it kind of establishes how
New York isn't covered in gooey gooey
webbing right ever and ever and why a
number of criminals get away if it's
kind of like a pizzas free yeah I did my
part
great and then one last one Lucas mucus
husks Eric what's more clunky what does
my clunky mean all right so my clunky
solo over my dead body my clunky this is
in a new hope it's a grito and Han Solo
standoff in the Mos Eisley cantina and
the scene that has been notoriously
changed over and over again by Lucas in
the 97 special edition release they he
added the bolt of a gritos blaster fire
to make it look like Greedo shot first
when in the original Han just shot first
preemptively latest version on Disney
plus they added yet again another detail
of Greedo saying Mac lanky and people
are like what the hell does this mean
well according to Brian Young it looks
from on Twitter he established that
McClung key is a hotties word translated
to this will be the end of you so whole
phrase yeah the whole phrase my clunky
and it's kind of ironic obviously
because it's gonna be the end of him in
this moment but it's it doesn't come out
of nowhere because he pointed out back
in Phantom Menace jar jar's goofing
around and he pisses off the bull though
I getting that crap Oliver stable and
Cibola jumps on him and he says so yeah
so it's been established in Star Wars
Canon before so if you had a real sharp
Easter Egg I you you wouldn't have
batted an eye at my clunky been in there
other than they just leave the scene
alone and leave it alone leave it alone
so there you go that's what that's what
my clunky means do I think it belongs in
that scene uh yeah probably just
deserves to be left alone alright Eric
what do you read this one what was your
worst date experience
mmm-hmm okay I've had I've had some that
are just kind of like hey I've had dates
I've had dates back in the days when I
was doing online dating well there is
one where we like date like like you're
my web girlfriend uh or no that was
catfishing that's a different episode
the interesting bad one was a lady I met
through the Improv Theater that we used
to perform at and we went to the Grove
in LA it's basically a big outdoor mall
and in West Hollywood and we went to a
burger place at the Grove you can get
your it's a great place to park because
most places validate we went to a burger
place that was new and did not validate
and for the remaining 90 minutes of this
date were us trying to find a place for
me to validate my parking cuz I didn't
want to pay $15 so you were the I
dragged I was the [ __ ] I dragged her
to coffee bean because I went through my
wallet I'm like oh I have a gift card a
coffee bean I'll just get I'll just use
this gift card and I went to coffee bean
and they're like oh this gift cards
expired oh my god fine I'll just pay the
495 and I'm like hey validate my Taylor
did she pay the 495 and and they're like
oh we don't validate here
where does validate the Grove and I'm
going from place to place um like where
is where can we validate and she's ready
to go but I'm just like okay why don't
we go to the movie theater cuz I know
this movie theater validates but I go in
there and like she's like we didn't see
a movie and I'm like well just lie and
say we did shut up Eric you're yelling
I'm scared and this whole time she's
like god this guy she's 15 bucks and
then I go in and then I say oh can I
just go Val they might take in they're
like where's your tickets WC movie and
I'm like yeah I saw a movie I look to
her and she goes we threw it away I'm
like forcing her to lie to this uh sure
and and he goes what movie did he see
and I look to her again uh sure by the
way watch reduce all the time she looks
up at one of the other theaters where
you can see that the title the move you
know time she's like didn't we see we
see and it was that that Nicolas Holt's
zombie love movie yeah warm bodies warm
bodies and I'm like yeah yeah we're
bodies this idiots gonna think we were
telling the truth so he's like okay yeah
fine we get a validated and we went on
two more dates it didn't really go
anywhere in a fizzled out I wonder why I
don't know I feel like I nailed it I
thought of a date that
was awkward and uncomfortable and
appropriate because this is post
Valentine's Day they were shooting this
because it was a Valentine's Day date I
invited someone over to my apartment I
was hosting a like kind of singles thing
but it was very clear like instead of
the thing we're take let's all drown our
misery together and [ __ ] on Valentine's
Day it was like come to this party and
let's try to hook up with somebody wait
was this in college I think I was at
this one yeah uh you were no you very
much were because I invited a girl to
join me and I thought she was into me
we'd been hanging out a lot and I was
like well here is Valentine's Day it's
the obvious next step uh and she's there
and we're talking but like she's
suddenly like uh oh I don't I don't want
to give off that energy so she's being
very like I only want to be friends
don't people want to be friends at my
like party where I put red pillowcases
on the the lampshade it's I remember
this try to make it all sexy and I made
those strawberry trunk covered
strawberries and stuff at a certain
point I realize like oh okay she's not
into me so I go why don't you just go
make out with Eric wait hold on and she
did and you guys made out on the couch
and then later she and I did get
together but she told me that right
before she made hell yeah she at first
she went to the bathroom if she puked
for a while cuz we got really drunk and
then she went and made out this is my
most comfortable question yeah alright
guys that's what this show is all about
making you write cringe in the comments
all right if you have a questions versus
you want to stay answer in a future
episode be sure to let us know using the
hashtag a big question we'll feature it
in the show we have a long list and that
some of you have been tweeting this
stuff and it's it's on the list we're
gonna get to it we're gonna get through
all your biggest questions because we
love tackling these in this kind of
format where we get to drink be sure to
also mail us if you if you like to use
stamps mail us at RPI box the post
office needs this be sure to follow us
at new rock stars on all social media
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
your nerdy news updates and follow
Phillip at Phillip meliha to follow me
at ei boss
hey guys we'll see you next week bye